hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to I don't even know now
that's the name of the game I found this
after I played the world's easiest game
in the quiz category and so I don't know
what it's about but I'm gonna play it
boy
okay fine
three two one go which men stole to the
cookie cookie no is me i hain't have
arms myself is not man you know you know
you know oh hi welcome to the party
little guy how you doing next mission
click in Steve is that Steve oh hi oh
excuse me sorry sorry oh okay I was
gonna kill them this seems bad no Steve
don't do it oh my pet next mission where
how'd you make a splode no key no this
Blanc swamp oh he of the keys in whoo
all right oh well you're not allowed
okay next mission cover his Oh his
tasteful nudes need to be covered up
yeah boss defeat defeat mr. clown how
how do I do that
honka-honka do I blow him up do I be to
blow him how do I do that
hello oh oh he's sad oh oh
draw what am i drawing oh hi that's not
that's not a drawing it's very abstract
art
[ __ ] next mission what light are hotter
oh my god oh wow this one oh [ __ ] okay
fix rocket plays pizza obviously it
needs to go up in there this 2times
booster I guess gives points to
dexterity just shove that behind there I
guess
Oh put beets in okay the plant in put
gear okay find me who is you Oh
airport security your nipples are real
dangerous today so paper or plastic
ma'am Oh next mission anybody home
ding-dong Bing bong break in through the
window dong party in your house all
night long
anybody Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing oh hi
yes hello good you is to life of to
party I'm also flying above it I think
I'm gonna die oh good look at baby oh
[ __ ] yeah next mission dance show kid
oh hell yeah let's keep serving next
mission enjoy my surround sounds yes yes
ok next mission make and wish which came
true I that makes it hard to masturbate
5 a claw hand deal or not deal oh stop
are you sure I don't know
oh hello binky oh no hearing it oh yes I
see that one
Jesus comfy okay well it's very stealthy
to be oh no oh baby pretty stealthy baby
Oh turtle the stealthiest of the mammals
robo not very stealthy ninja next
mission deny agreement official contract
I agree to eat nasty food signed it I
agreed oh no I didn't want that mr.
funky hey oh where are hairy people's
bathroom we are hi oh my is lost chamber
secrets very dangerous hide evidence oh
these are my porn oh I don't need these
anymore
Oh in the recycle bin okay where's my
fireworks I don't know why they'd be in
the grill but okay
it's locked why is the grill locked Oh
boss to feed your license mister how
about a Best Buy gift card choose not to
win cuz if you mention the game you just
lost the game snips all those dangerous
snips I knew the police would come after
my nip some day I mean it was totally
ridiculous and [ __ ] but it was so
fast-paced I didn't even know the
difference
it appeals to my ATD so anyway that is I
don't even know who so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know we thought this down the comments
below I have no idea who even made this
but uh if you did congratulations this
was kind of fun so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]
you